mesdames et messieurs bonsoir otages en
iran la crise demeure très aiguë mais il
n'y a pas eu de nouveau degré dans
l'escaladé en tout cas ce qu'il y a eu à
téhéran c'est une série d'ordres et de
contrôle
on avait annoncé ainsi au milieu de la
journée comme monsieur banny sabres
responsable iranien des affaires
étrangères partait de mac pour new york
afin d'y participer à la prochaine
session du conseil de sécurité mais une
dépêche de 19h47 nous a dit que monsieur
banny cendre ne se rendrait pas aux
nations unies pourquoi devrait-il partir
pour une partie le pas pour le moment on
ne comprend pas encore très bien
alors que les otages de l'ambassade des
etats-unis à téhéran commence
aujourd'hui de leur quatrième semaine de
captivité
deux médiateurs de bonne volonté l'un
mandaté par unesco notre part lui-même
cherche une solution d'envoyer de
l'unesco mme ce show de mcbride disait
ce matin rentrait à paris que selon lui
si le gouvernement des états unis
déclarent qu'ils désirent sincèrement
établir de bonnes relations avec le
peuple iranien
la réouverture d'un dialogue serait où
ce sera possible le deuxième budget est
improvisé de débuter américain georges
hansen républicains à idaho a suggéré
lui que le gouvernement américain créé
une commission d' enquête sur les
agissements du chat notamment aux états
unis
suggestion que monsieur bani sadr a
relevé et commenté dans une interview
qu'il vient d'accorder à notre envoyé
spécial à téhéran philippe rochot la
voici qui sait si demain le dossier du
chad
dans le must des affaires étrangères des
états unis ou dans suez et se révèle à
tout le monde et le congrès fait une
enquête qui perd un grand et scandale
vous êtes sûr à ce moment là le peuple
américaines comme nous ne il n'exigera
pas avec insistance l'extradition du
shah les américains apparemment sont
contre la faire de l'occupation de
l'ambassade américaine moi aussi je suis
comme un sage indien être content
vous pourrez être contenue le dire cela
cela équivaudrait à céder à un certain
chantage que de livrer le chat ne pas du
tout parce que c'est un problème c'est
pas nous nous n'avons pas créé ce
problème
bon si le premier joue après
nos victoires on attaqué l'ambassade qui
est cette année dans le monde tout
entier
personne même les américains n'auraient
pas dû dire à mots justes tout le monde
savait très bien que la massane
c'était vraiment le bastion de du régime
ben ali
bon le vrai centre de gouvernement
devraient la vraie cour en paya
certaines ambassades dont on a attaqué
fini voilà alors l'annulation du voyage
de venice objet d'une dépêche qui est
tombée à 20 heures une grille et je la
reçois cette annulation a été fait a dit
le porte parole du conseil de la
révolution pour deux raisons parce que
l'iran observe la période sacrée de
deuil musulmans du mois de moharram et à
cause de la proximité du référendum sur
les futures institutions iraniennes
prévue le 10 référendum pour le deux
dessins et pendant ce temps les
personnalités iraniennes multiplie les
déclarations on peut dire les menaces le
ministre iranien du pétrole monsieur m'a
une phare assure que tous les pays
qu'ils s'opposeraient à la république
islamique d'iran seraient privés de leur
pétrole et de son côté l'amiral madani
commandant en chef de la marine déclaré
la marine iranienne que les forces
armées iraniennes rendrons coup pour
coup en cas d'action militaire des
américains
mais l'amiral ne crois pas semble-t-il à
une guerre généralisée en raison de la
situation géographique de l'iran qui est
rappelle-t-il comme un morceau de choix
enviée par deux gros chat qui ronronne
mais n'osent pas sortir leurs griffes
fin de citation il s'agit d' évidemment
ce qui concerne ses sharks de l'union
soviétique et des états unis
dans le contexte international actuel un
nombre de plus en plus élevé de gens se
posent une question très grave
la solution à tous les conflits ne
pourrait-elle pas être la guerre bien
sûr c'est une question est effrayante
mais fondamentale elle sera posée demain
lundi à 20h35 ici même dans question de
temps un débat sur un thème angoissant
avec un direct des invités que michel
poniatowski ou edgar pisani et pour les
interroger
louis berio et georges bortoli demain
donc cette interrogation c'est grave
la solution la guerre
cambodge excusez moi ce matin voici qui
est arrivé à paris le prince adam siano
piano pu jadis un apôtre du neutralisme
puis l'ami des vietnamiens dans leur
combat contre les états unis
renversé à cause de cela par le maréchal
london le prince que dans ce huit
prisonniers des khmers rouges et il
réapparut assez récemment lorsque les
vietnamiens envahir le cambodge pour
certains le prince peut sembler dépassée
en fait son crédit est toujours
considérable dans le peuple cambodgien
et il pourrait apparaître comme la
meilleure solution au drame devenu
permanent de son pays ce matin très tôt
il y avait parmi ceux qui vinrent
l'accueillir à sa descente d'avion à
paris jean-pierre elkabbach et services
6 heures 15 ce matin dans le salon
d'honneur de l'aéroport de roissy des
cambodgiens psalmodie des paroles de
bienvenue après quatre années d'absence
le prince norodom sihanouk revient en
france il y à un moment d'émotion qu'on
le prince retrouve de vieux compagnons
et puis il va faire une déclaration il
remercie le gouvernement français qui
l'accueille en tant qu'ami mais sa
déclaration est aussi et surtout une
déclaration de guerre aux ennemis du
cambodge n'ont plus le choix
par delà leur division ils sont tous
d'accord sur le fait que nourrir pour
mourir
il vaut mieux se battre jusqu'au dernier
contre les colonisateurs de leur pays
la meilleure solution celles qui restent
au fond des choses et qui permettrait
peut-être la renaissance d'un cabochard
indépendant et neutre est la réunion une
conférence internationale sur le proche
du type de genève 1954 je crois contre
la france
de nombreuses puissances défendrai
l'idée d'une telle conférence si elle
avait quelque chance de se tenir
or elle est irréalisable dans un proche
avenir puisque les pays qui détiennent
les clés de la guerre et de la paix dans
la région s'y oppose résolument
et la surprise la plus émouvante
attention à nous qu'à l'extérieur du
salon d'honneur plusieurs centaines de
cambodgiens qui n'ont pas hésité à se
lever très tôt ce matin pour venir
encourager celui qui est pour eux
l'homme de la dernière chance vous
retrouverez le prince norodom sihanouk
après-demain dans les dossiers de
l'écran dans cette émission le prince
sera interviewé ou non de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 par paul nahon
mais les dossiers de l'écran comme un
soin titre exceptionnel à 21h après le
programme spécial une heure en direct
avec le président de la république
monsieur giscard d'estaing il sera
interviewé par alain duhamel et gérard
saint paul
cet entretien le quatrième du genre est
donc donné cette fois ci sur antenne 2
et il sera animé par notre directeur de
l'information jean pierre elkabbach
après cette parenthèse et ses
indications je reviens au cambodge où le
front national de libération du public
maire a demandé cet après midi
l'ouverture d'un pont routier entre le
cambodge et la thaïlande sous la
protection des casques bleus de l'onu
pour transporter d'extrême urgence des
secours vers les régions cambodgienne
les plus touchées par l'effroyable
famine qui a fait des centaines de
milliers voire des millions de morts sur
le plan militaire et sans parler des
khmers rouges naturellement il existe
plusieurs organisations cambodgienne à
l'intérieur du cambodge et qui se réfère
à rodome sihanouk la seule armée que le
prince ait reconnu jusqu'ici
officiellement c'est le molina qu'un
abréviation de libération nationale du
kampuchea qu'en voiture
c'est à dire cambodge nous ont envoyés
spéciaux ont rencontré au cambodge même
sans leader comme auxiliaire nous sommes
ici à la base militaire du camp 511 à
quelques kilomètres à l'intérieur du
cambodge
il est 7 heures du matin les soldats du
molina cas le mouvement de libération
nationale du cambodge se prépare à
partir en opération
bardé de foulards et d'amulettes qui
doivent les rendre invulnérables aux
balles ils sont les soldats d'une armée
hétéroclite où l'on trouve des enfants
des vétérans de l'armée de lon nol des
patriotes et des pillards
une arme et sous-équipés leurs armes peu
nombreuses dates de la guerre américaine
en indochine
ils n'ont pas d'armements lourds peu de
munitions cette pénurie explique le
genre de guerre que mène le mot dinaqua
contre les vietnamiens
quelles sont les méthodes de votre lutte
la guérilla rocheteau ou semble très
faible en effectifs
nous sommes très faible en un moment
seule la guérilla peut nous aider
quel genre d'opération est ce que vous
menez contre les vietnamiens a bien
premièrement l'harcèlement c'est
toujours l'harcèlement nous fatiguons
l'ennemi nous les harcelons jour et nuit
nous pouvons enfin la médina mienne elle
est très forte mais il faut faire
quelque chose c'est notre terre c'est
notre peuple
il faut les défendre
les défendre car le peuple et la
civilisation primaires sont en danger de
mort un exemple les derniers survivants
de l'orchestré national de phnom penh se
sont retrouvés par hasard au camp 511
toutes musiques anciennes ayant été
interdite par les khmers rouges
c'est la première fois depuis cinq ans
qu'ils peuvent rejouer
c'est aussi la première fois depuis cinq
ans que ces réfugiés entendent les
grands classiques de leur culture
10h du matin comme si léa donne le
signal du départ
la stratégie du moulinas cas comme celle
des autres groupes de résistance et 5
préserver leurs sanctuaires le long de
la frontière protéger les camps de
réfugiés
c'est une guerre d'embuscades et de
coups de main ou le renseignement est
vite à un éclaireur est arrivé il donne
les dernières informations sur les
troupes vietnamiennes à coxyde et à
défaut d'armes de discipline et
d'entraînement comme si les rails son
armée ne manquent pas d'ardeur pour se
battre contre les vietnamiens le molina
cas affirment avoir 5000 hommes mais
tous ne sont pas armés et entraînés il y
à beaucoup d'autres mouvements ou front
de libération au cambodge mais le molina
cas et pour l'instant la seule force
militaire à l'intérieur du pays qui soit
reconnue officiellement par le prince
yano à 13h comme s'il est à apprendre
dans un campement traversée que son
propre camp 511 est attaquée par l'armée
thaïlandaise
il faut leur porter secours
une heure plus tard aux abords du camp
511 toujours bombardée par l'armée
thaïlandaise
les premières victimes parmi les
réfugiés
c'est en effet le camp civile qui
regroupe 70 mille réfugiés qui est visé
comme si l'oea se rend à l'infirmerie du
camp on lui explique pourquoi l'armée
thaïlandaise a déclenché cette attaque
les cambodgiens se sont se sont entrés
en territoire taille pour acheter des
provisions se sont aventurés surtout
pour chercher de nous à bien
ils ont ils ont l'objet des brigandages
mais n'a pas les autorités sefa civils
ou militaires
alors la pédiatre commence parce que
nous nous nous les méditer nous
défendons aussi la pop et dance aussi
s'il est bien le mouline à cannes en
trois mouvements
une cinquantaine de morts et de blessés
pour un simple avertissement 1 rappelle
aussi que les réfugiés cambodgiens ont
beaucoup d'ennemis et pas d'amis dans
leur malheur les quelques 500 mille
réfugiés angkor au cambodge
non que des protecteurs comme comme si
les uns ou les autres chefs militaires
des autres mouvements ses protecteurs
par manque d'armes de médicaments de
nourriture sont souvent incapables de
remplir leur tâche
pendant que ce sujet filmé se dérouler
sur votre écran je reçus une dépêche afp
de terrain la libye et l'iran lance un
appel solennel à tous les pays arabes
pour qu'il rompe toutes leurs relations
politiques diplomatiques et économiques
avec les états unis en arabie saoudite
les forces de l'ordre ont donné l'assaut
fatick retranché dans la grande mosquée
de la mecque et elles contrôlent la
totalité de ce lieu saint on attend sous
peu un communiqué qu'ils croient ton
indiquera le nombre exact des rebelles
et celui des affaires françaises
on apprend de sources officielles
l'hospitalisation ce soir de monsieur
jean matteoli de tout nouveau ministre
du travail monsieur interdit a été
victime d'un malaise cardiaque à son
domicile après midi on en ignore encore
la gravité
il a été conduit en tout cas dans une
ambulance de réanimation escorté par
deux motards à l'hôpital militaire du
val de grâce
aujourd'hui a pris fin le 1er congrès de
l'association des élus communistes et
républicains
dans son discours de clôture monsieur
marchait sans les prêts une fois de plus
à ce qu'il appelle la collusion entre
messieurs françois mitterrand et jacques
chirac
mais le secrétaire général du parti
communiste a surtout dénoncé avec
véhémence
l'attitude des socialistes dans les
municipalités d'union de la gauche le
parti socialiste n'hésite pas à devenir
menaçant à recourir au chantage pur et
simple à nous lancer un véritable diktat
c'est ainsi
dans un document qu'ils viennent
d'adopter les élus socialistes sommes
littéralement les élus communistes de
voter le budget les yeux fermés dans
toutes les municipalités à direction
socialiste sous peu précise le document
de se placer pas abstentions ou votes
contre en situation de retrait de
délégation nous n'aurions plus qu'à
choisir
en quelque cent entre eux la soumission
ou la démission que personne ne compte
sur nous pour cv à de telles pressions
un robot des fameuses convergence rpr
parti socialiste réponse ce soir de
monsieur pons secrétaire général du
mouvement gaulliste disant en substance
dans une conférence de presse à l'issue
d'une réunion avec les responsables
départementaux du mouvement
de toute façon le rpr s'il fait appel à
l'électorat socialiste n'a jamais eu
l'intention de faire appel aux appareils
la partie politique
ce soir au club de la presse d'europe
numéro un monsieur andré bergeron le sto
des redevances ouvrière s'est déclaré
convaincu que le gouvernement allait
décider dans les jours qui viennent la
réduction de la durée maximale du
travail de 48 à 46 heures par semaine et
selon submergeront cette réduction
deviendra effective avant la fin de
l'année fin aujourd'hui du congrès de la
cftc à strasbourg ce syndicat qui se
veut je cite le plus résolument
réformiste a réaffirmé sa volonté de
poursuivre la politique contractuelle et
monsieur jean bernard a été réélu
secrétaire général pour deux sous
l'agent de saison littéraire paraît
vraiment bien engagé sinon bien parti
jour après jour le monde des livres un
registre déclaration démonstration
indignation à propos du trucage ou d'une
autre cage
des prix littéraires depuis que lundi
dernier le goncourt a été attribué à
l'écrivain canadien
antonine maillet pour son livre pélagie
la charrette les commentaires vont bon
train surtout à la suite d'une
déclaration d'hervé bazin alain
gillot-pétré vous présente seul aux 6
tout a commencé lundi dernier après la
proclamation du prix goncourt
l'une des trois grandes maisons
d'édition abonnés au prix venait d'être
couronné en la personne d'anthony nommé
hier hervé bazin président des goncourt
affirma alors que les trois maisons en
question
gallimard grasset le seuil publient est
à elle seule 80 % de la production
romanesque française couronnée en la
personne d'anthony in may est hervé
bazin président des goncourt affirma
alors que les trois maisons en question
gallimard grasset le seuil publient est
à elle seule 80 % de la production
romanesque française un propos qui
provoqua des éditeurs la colère monsieur
je suis en colère qui ne le serait pas
c'est vrai c'est faux archi faux
et certainement monsieur bazin doit au
moins se tromper du simple au double et
ou commander ce qui m'a choqué battu
diamant c'est que monsieur bazin
finalement ce fait l'agent de trois
éditeurs il s'adresse aux jeunes
jouteurs en disant envoyer vos
manuscrits à sa 3 à ces trois éditeurs
et à personne d'autre si vous voulez
avoir une vraie chance d'avoir le prix
goncourt
bon c'est proprement scandaleux il
cautionne tout césure et littéraire
inféodés à certaines maisons et qui
démarchent comment dire non propres
auteurs en leur disant venez chez nous
celle endroits publics où je suis
rémunéré et je vous donnerai ma voix
pour avoir appris tout ça est lamentable
moi je propose qu'on agisse en ce qui me
concerne je demande notre d'autres
éditeurs nous rejoindre je refuse de
participer aux prix et aux opérations
d'accord je crois qu'ils seront d'accord
mais de toute façon je dis bien je
refuse de participer au prix je refuse
que d'envoyer mes livres aux jurés et si
lendemain attribue un jeudi
je ne refuserais je crois qu'à un
certain moment on ne peut plus n'est ce
pas participer à quelque chose qui
ressemble à de la boue et qui vous
submerge à votre mais si vos auteurs
vous quitte pour aller justement dans
ces maisons là
on les prie pas c'est un pari sur l'eau
n'était que je fais et les auteurs dans
cette polémique
à qui revient le prix à l'écrivain ou à
l'éditeur jean marc roberts tout frais
prix renaudot
je pense que c'est mon roman qui a
obtenu le prix c'est moi maintenant
depuis le 19 novembre 13 heures je
n'impose plus la moindre question là
dessus je sais que je suis débarrassé
des prix je sais que je suis c'est fini
je sais que en plus ma chance a été
d'avoir un prix aussi important très
très jeune c'est à dire que 25 ans
modiano m'a dit tu as gagné 10 ans lui
il les a perdus peut-être je sais que
j'ai gagné dix ans il est soulagé l'on a
je suis soulagé je dis ouf
avant tout on n'irait plus courir les
prix ben non non ça va être formidable
j'ai sortir me rendant en mars/avril
tranquille je partir en vacances tout
serait fini alors que ça allait partir
en vacances quand on arrive qu'ils sont
en septembre avec toujours la petite
angoisse de se dire bonjour m démolir
crois que bon ça y est c'est fini mais
c'est un jeu c'est une loterie est un
concours à un muscle une course de
chevaux je crois surtout une course de
chevaux déclina vont plus loin
geneviève dormann se moquent éperdument
des prix littéraires moi complètement
alors je refuse d'être un cheval dans
cette course et je préfère vendre les
livres être un best-seller plutôt 80
lauréats prix littéraire parce que vous
voulez c'est un public urbain ses rimes
en moi je veux qu'on me disais je
connais mes livres mais pour votre
talent pour mon talent et pour d'autres
raisons des raisons commerciales
habituelles qu'on voit toujours quand et
éditeurs bon trafic est les prix
s'arrange pour acheter des jurés enfin
tout ce qu'on sait tous qui êtes vous
quand ils sont saouls mais si vous
disent que c'est parce que vous n'avez
pas obtenu deux prix vous auriez bien
aimé peut-être
j'ai aimé une fois dans ma vie parce que
j'avais besoin d'argent je les loupés
jamais plus je ne mettra en compétition
je publie mes livres au mois de juin et
tout ce que vous dites est un jeu
d'ombrés monétaire assez triste assez
consternant il m'a elle l est
les éditeurs sont d'abord des marchands
de papier il faut pas oublier ça quand
même pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils
agissent autrement si j'étais éditeur je
ferai peut-être autant demain lundi on
attribuera en tout cas deux nouveaux
prix portant le femina et le médicis
c'est bien connu la france reste le pays
du système bd comme des bruyères et
c'est encore plus vrai actuellement avec
la recherche en général les énergies de
remplacement et en particulier des
carburants recherche qui vient
d'ailleurs de faire l'objet d'un congrès
à tours parmi les débrouillards la
nourrice l'association nationale pour
l'utilisation des ressources
énergétiques française c'est un petit
groupe d'amis et techniciens puisant
surtout leur optimisme dans les
possibilités agricole du pays
vous savez peut-être pas ce que c'est
que cette tubercule est bien c'est de
les lions tus du vérose us tout
simplement du topinambour
alors comment que sont le topinambour
est bien de deux manières la première
vous la connaissez pour certains ceux
qui ont vécu en tout cas la dernière
guerre mondiale et les restrictions on
le manchot enfin on le mange est chaud
ou froid en salade il paraît que c'était
un peu moins mauvais quand c'est en
salade et froid on en faisait même
parfois du tabac avec les fans qui sont
d'ailleurs ces chants cette saison ça
donne est paraît-il des odeurs très
forte et très dur et puis une seconde
manière de le consommer depuis très peu
de temps on en fait une espèce de
distillation une espèce d'alcool c'est
de l'agrocarburant je vous présente donc
le super topinambours et en faut 10 kg
pour faire un litre
mais oui ça marche très bien et même
écologiquement ce banache n'est rien
d'autre que de la vapeur aux relents de
prune du pays et cela pourrait marcher
avec bien d'autres agrocarburants de
distillation betteraves sur plus de
fruits ou encore cannes à sucre comme au
brésil pays où des milliers de voitures
roulent talent agrocarburants et qui en
1984 contrat sans doute 4 millions de
véhicules à alcool partielle ou totale
alors pourquoi du topinambour plutôt que
du rutabaga par exemple parce que c'est
une plante facile généreuse qui s'adapte
pratiquement à toutes les terres est
température et parce que c'est une des
plus alcoolisée gènes du monde un
hectare de 2,2 topinambours ayant une
production minimum de 40 tonnes à
l'hectare représente 5 à 6000 litres de
carburant de carburant de qualité à peu
près égale à l'essence et il y à 14
millions 14 millions d'hectares
disponibles actuellement en france de
terre qui sont in employés et qui sont
capables d'être cultivé on a mille ici
du jus de topinambours qui est tentant
de bruit actuellement l'alcool passe
distillée la vapeur dans la colonne de
distillation et ses coulisses et d'un le
réfrigérant et il s'écoule ici par le
vase
alors effectivement on le voit on voit
ses cours et et il y en a déjà eu à peu
près la valeur d'un vers la performance
semblable aux précédentes mais ont pu
augmenter la compression consommation +
10 % avec le système alcool total cas de
ce véhicule utilisant un peu d'essence
pour démarrer à froid et après quelques
kilomètres le chauffeur tourne le
robinet du super topinambours cette
voiture qui était expérimentale
fonctionne uniquement à l'alcool de
topinambours avec un réservoir d'alcool
qu'on adjoint à l'avant et uniquement
comme transformation le changement du
gîte l'heure il ya une autre formule qui
est qui serait parfaite
c'est le mélange 50% alcool 50% essence
ça nécessiterait un réglage du
carburateur fait par le constructeur
il paraît que l'alcool et en particulier
l'alcool agricole détruits ou noir s'ils
me ferai ce que c'est vrai non les
moteurs actuels qui sont construits avec
des matériaux et des aciers spéciaux ne
sont plus attaquable par les alcools ou
par la route ou par ce qui est est ce
qui peut détruire les soupapes autres la
relève par l'alcool ne fait plus rire
et comme l'imagination fait le plein
rêve un simple
c'est vrai nous avons un peu forcer le
destin pourtant l'agrocarburant le super
copine n'est pas utopique c'est
peut-être même un espoir a commencé pour
les milliers de communes à terre impôts
encore faut-il que les constructeurs
automobiles s'y intéresse autrement qu
en souriant que les pétroliers ne fasse
pas barrage et que l'état ne l'asean pas
de taxes l'idée est viable
commercialement par exemple avec des
coopératives et l'opinion on a assez de
voir des inventions partir à l'étranger
pour être prise au sérieux
après avoir rejoint la nuit noire des
dossiers chez nous trop vite de classer
comme doux rêveur l'un des plus grands
musiciens français ramona sans doute pas
la popularité qu'il mérite auprès du
grand public malgré le succès des indes
galantes
mais voici que depuis une semaine et
sous l'égide du ministère de la culture
et de la communication se déroule ainsi
que leur âme aux destinées à faire
découvrir un musicien parfois oubliées
ou même un compris ceux ci que va
s'étendre sur toute l'année prochaine
autour de l'oeuvre du compositeur et du
clavecin général ainsi que sous forme de
cours d'interprétation de conférences et
de concerts venez par les plus grands
que sinistre français et étrangers pour
commencer ce reportage monique atlan a
choisi un extrait d en galante
interprété par kenneth gilberte un
artiste canadien
il
m
et
rameau oublier rarement retrouvées
jamais musiciens n'aura autant souffert
des changements d'humeur qui font
l'histoire de la libye déjà de scop
excusez nous s'il vous plaît
a auteuil victoire dans le tiercé grand
prix notre confrère paris tueur d'un
cheval exceptionnel sans abrisme ans non
seulement il a porté victorieusement la
charge écrasante de 72 kg mais encore
c'est presque un miraculé après un
accident la saison dernière on avait dû
lui mettre une plaque et des vis dans le
genou et j'ai comme cela qu'il course en
restant pour la seconde fois les chevaux
vont sauter la rivière des tribunes sans
bride temps kazakh rayée bleu ciel
groupe le top grenat est en tête depuis
le début
accompagnée dé quoi taille et enlace
petite fontaine de ce rytme sierre et le
clos laurent sûr de sa supériorité cent
restants emmène de bout en bout pour
éviter d'être gêné par les fuites
éventuelles et surtout régler la lure de
la course à sa convenance temps là c'est
quoi ta et de sa rue nice hier le
colorant petite fontaine ont toujours
fait partie du groupe de tête langard
détournant cent restants est nettement
détaché pour venir sauter la double
barrière petite fontaine l'attaquent
sérieusement suivie de miss hier temps
l'as et kwata et deux séries qui se
rapproche sans restant à toujours
davantage pour aborder la dernière heure
mais petite fontaine s'accrochent
courageusement mais sierre gagne terrain
de serre et le colorant et quoi taille
se maintiennent en bonne position et sur
le plat sans veste ans qui a une pointe
de vitesse remarquable malgré les 72 kg
qui pousse
il aura à faire avec petite fontaine
tout devient très dangereux dans le
match passionnante cent restants la
gagner encore en champions derrière nuit
petite centaine policière sur une deux
révélations sur ces 9 8 et apporter dans
le premier cas 500-550 dans le désordre
697 150 le clos laurent se fait
plusieurs atteintes il souffrait dans la
course il a été arrêté le temps lundi et
bien sûr la moitié nord du pays il sera
ou deviendra très nuageux et
relativement doux parfois brumeux
bruines éparses près des côtes et dans
le nord sur le reste de la france de
temps restera froid et souvent brumeux
le matin avec des brouillards localement
givrants
cependant on prévoit des éclaircies
l'après midi elles seront plus
nombreuses près de la méditerranée
notre édition est terminée vous avez
rendez vous vers 3h15 alain qui vous
donnera des dernières informations de
cette journée de dimanche et demain vous
retrouverez pour présenter antenne 2010
patrick lecocq et pour présenter
l'édition de mateur patrick poivre
d'arvor pour ce faire